bonjour je me présente je m'appelle
Jérôme chaptiou je viens du tampon je
suis d'origine mauricienne et je fais la
cuisine boricienne la cuisine
authentique de l'île Maurice
voilà j'ai un petit restaurant à au
tampon à 430 rue Hubert de Lille que
voilà ça fait depuis un an maintenant
que je suis
d'activité je me suis présenté au
concours de challenge de créateur dans
le catégorie Innovation et voilà
j'espère
d'être parmi les douze pourquoi pas et
agrandir ma société
pourquoi pas monter une sur
Saint-Denis ou la possession parce que
il y a beaucoup de gens de toute l'île
qui viennent chez nous ou goûter
notamment le dalle pourri le farta avec
le vinda et de ton tout ça qui enfin
j'ai un j'ai un site une page Facebook
que vous pouvez voir avec toutes les
photos tout ce que je présente tout ce
que toute ma cuisine que je fais quoi
l'innovation c'est que il y a que il y a
que moi qui fait ça à la Réunion les
préparations c'est typiquement
mauricienne c'est des trucs que vous
trouvez dans des petits restos au coin
de la rue et tout et moi j'ai décidé
d'emmener ça sur des grandes tables et
faire découvrir ça au peuple réunionnais
et si vous venez dans mon resto il y a
aussi l'ambiance de la musique Sega et
tout avec nos petites sauce à l'ail
piment fait maison toutes les
petit truc fait maison voilà
bonjour je m'appelle Joël delaclo j'ai
54 ans j'habite à Saint-Paul je suis
auto-entrepreneur j'ai ouvert mon propre
entreprise depuis 1er août 2013 je
travaille dans le bien-être je pratique
des massages et des soins énergétiques
je pratique la réflexologie plantaire le
massage à l'huile je suis praticienne du
premier deuxième degré en soins
énergétique le massage assis et le soin
de l'oreille le massage d'oreilles avec
les bougies OPI mon but c'est de créer
mon mot local hors de ma maison pour
séparer ma vie professionnelle et ma vie
travail mon but aussi c'est de pouvoir
prendre quelqu'un pour pouvoir
travailler avec moi plus tard et je
compte aussi me continuer d'autres
formations pour pouvoir mettre d'autres
massages en pratique les clients m'en
demandent aussi voilà et puis on vit
dans un monde de plus en plus stressé on
a besoin de se détendre de se faire
masser après une journée de travail les
pieds en souffre le corps en souffre le
moral en souffre on a besoin de se
détendre j'en profite pour présenter mon
logo c'est instant cocon c'est un
dépliant qui vous explique un petit peu
tout ce que je pratique comme massage
bonjour je m'appelle Coulon Philippe
j'ai 46 ans et je me présente dans la
catégorie les créateurs innovants je
fais dans le lavage auto filote lavage
c'est exactement dans la sans eau la
vache sans eau on va dire dans
l'esthétique de la voiture pour donner
aux clients la satisfaction du d'un
lavage impeccable alors spécificité
c'est de prendre des produits en plus
écologique qui n'attire pas
l'environnement qui va vraiment donner
un effet et un rendu impeccable aux
véhicules donc c'est à dire en plus
d'éviter de l'eau parce que quand vous
utilisez de l'eau ça tache la
carrosserie si vous y suivez pas donc il
va redonner vraiment le brillant de la
carrosserie
alors au début quand j'ai commencé il y
en avait très peu et là je vois que ça
commence à fleurir mais après je moi je
me base sur la qualité de la prestation
de service de qualité donc si vous
voulez vous retrouver moi je suis sur le
parking de Sainte-Marie au cinéma tous
les mercredis et samedi après je me
déplace chez les particuliers les
entreprises j'étais dans dans la
pâtisserie donc comme j'avais fait tout
toucher à tout dans la pâtisserie j'ai
décidé vraiment de tourner une page en
venant ici à la Réunion je me suis lancé
dans la dans l'esthétique de la voiture
donc il m'a paru très bien parce que les
Réunionnais aiment bien leur voiture